so tell us about domino effect yeah
domino effect is the new feature I'm
trying to get off the ground it's
written by and being co-produced by the
writer david Flores who we teamed up to
kind of get the movie made and we have a
full package together for we've got a
ton of artwork for it it's a budgeted
between 500-600 $50,000 which for an
action film is really tight for the kind
of action we're doing it's a crazy story
about a X it's a story about horrible
picture so please forgive me it's a
story about an ex call girl who is
running away from her pimp her sadistic
pimp who said the pimp sends metrosexual
hood and an ex-con to go get her cross
country they get her and have to bring
her back and Domino is a pill and a half
the deal with she's just very feisty she
bites kick screams everything and and
he's did the stories of them bringing
her back for him to get payback to her
and in the middle of this there's a
gun-wielding monks who come either call
the offset monks and come in and just
create all court sorts of havoc and and
the the pimp is you know obsessed with
bulls and midland texas and it's a
pretty crazy story and a lot of fun and
it's kind of when i read the script I
was like yep that that sounds like me I
love to do that so we're trying to get
the project off the ground right now and
we actually have a Kickstarter campaign
right now actually about trying to get
some money so I can shoot a trailer
because princess pretty much killed me
financially as far as I can I can't
spend with kids on the way I can't spend
more money so I'm trying to get some
film is some some support to get the
trailer off the ground so we can
hopefully get financing so we're going
to be at afm this year trying to pitch
it and sell it and stuff like that so
we'll see well you seem to like feisty
female
yeah was like that as well what is it
about that type of female character
cause you know I i think the biggest
thing I've been asked that before like
all my stories always have a female lead
in it and they're usually very strong
women so I I just always find it more
fascinating having a woman in a better
place where a man don't really would be
you know you know men men action movies
are usually the norm but female action
films have to come up a little bit more
in the recent years but I just always
thought it's just more interesting you
know you watch Ridley and alien you know
you could have put that a guy could have
been Ridley you know you know Tomb
Raider you could add somebody else there
but you know there's like I always find
that strong women characters are just
they're just more interesting to me you
know and I just I love women you know I
love women and i love i love their
nature and I think the counter nature of
you know woman soft energy and motherly
and nurturing kind of energy as opposed
to a man's very aggressive and strong
and it was kind of like I like to
transplant that you know I'd like to
have those energy that energy you know
and a woman and she could still be
nurturing and caring and loving like my
character princess who is basically a
single mother who lost her family is
very nurturing and all this kind of
stuff but yet she can kick the hell out
of you and kill you if you if you mess
with her so I always find that duality
very interesting so maybe one day I'll
make a movie about a guy without you
know a leak male character which I got
it right soon it'll be easier to find a
house I'll tell you that it's very
difficult to finance a lead female
character but has only had full of
females that in the world actresses that
can finance action movies you know we
all want Angelina we all can't have them
but that's that's the truth but yeah I
just wanted more fascinating but having
this town